With Ken 26,
the purgation of the pilgrim is completed.
He has been going through the various stages of purgatory from pride,
as you remember to the scene of lust.
And,
uh,
in 27,
he crosses a wall of fire,
um,
so that he can be cleansed completely of all the stains that may be residual on
his soul and approach.
And then to the,
the,
the garden of Eden.
This is the,
uh,
the action,
that takes place in 27.
And Cantor 27 comes to a close with,
uh,
a passage that I would like to read to you and comment on.
It's at the end of Canto 27.
And these are really the last words that Virgil will,
will speak.
We will not hear from him again.
Um,
in fact,
from now on,
the pilgrim will be entitled on his own.
There's no dependency on him because it's sort of a actually very personal
moment now that it's a start.
Uh,
and,
and we'll see the drama that goes with this time of,
uh,
this,
this attainment of self mastery that,
uh,
Dante goes on dramatizing.
These are the last words,
uh,
that he speaks,
from lines,
uh,
one 30,
on,
uh,
the temporal fire and the terminal that has seen meaning Kruger,
Tori,
and,
and health,
which lasts forever.
My son and I come to a part where of mice I have of myself.
I discern no further.
This is the limitation of Virgil's vision.
This is from now on.
He will be following even the,
the geometry,
the arrangement of their journey will be completely reversed.
Up to now,
the pilgrim has been a disciple,
therefore one who follows the vestiges of the teacher.
Now the teacher with Ah,
AH,
stages we'll be following a Virgil,
he sees no further.
And actually I can anticipate for you the pathos of Virgil's departures
southern.
The departure when he,
the pilgrim most once a month needs him because Beatrice is approaching and the
terror that,
uh,
with a terror that Beatrice represents for the pilgrim,
the pilgrim would turn back and his eyes will never see a Virgil again.
Virtual has disappeared an instant before his vanishes and instant before
Beatrice arrives.
As if there's a hiatus,
a Dante's dramatizing the hiatus between the two guides and the tool,
uh,
particular stages of his own self knowledge and,
and,
and life.
So let me continue with this.
Thou that take henceforth they pleasure for God.
What an extraordinary line take them.
Hence supposed to day pressure for guide.
Uh,
this is the poem of desire in the sense that what pushes the pilgrim to go on
and a impels them to this journey of discovery and self discovery is really
desire.
Desire is,
uh,
the,
the moving force in him.
But now that language changes now in a sense,
a certain,
uh,
the first part of the journey is over and pleasure can become,
the guide,
uh,
the guidance of his own pleasure.
What he likes is to say,
in a sense,
it's another operational three.
We'll,
uh,
we'll talk more about,
the relationship between the actual pleasure and happiness,
the way down to,
we'll go and dramatizing it.
And,
and thinking about it in,
uh,
in,
in paradise that has come forth from the steep and narrow ways.
See The sun that shines on eyebrow.
See the grass near the earthly paradise.
See the grass,
the flowers and trees,
which the ground here brings forth of itself alone is this as if by Dante,
by taking his own pleasure,
uh,
as his guidance,
he's now his reached any Dimmick place is a virtual speaking of,
of,
of the pilgrim as if you were speaking of the ground that thrives,
uh,
until the ground,
the land producers spontaneously and now he's capable that spontaneous action
and spontaneous,
uh,
decisions to the fair eyes come rejoicing which weeping made come to commit me.
Come to thee.
Thou may sit or go among them,
uh,
to details or expressed very slides.
One is virtual is recapitulating in many ways.
Uh,
this first part of the journey,
the journey that began and in fair no one,
and then see ya in purgatory,
in the garden of Eden,
it began in the wilderness and then is in the garden.
This is,
this is the first step of a,
the first stage of the journey.
You can now are.
He remembers.
That's how he recapitulates the fair eyes.
That made me,
that begged me to come to your help when you were a lost in,
in,
in uh,
in and shipwrecked on the wilderness of in federal one,
so now a virtual is going back to that.
The second element is that this is the exercise now though may sit or go among
them now.
This is exactly the major temptation for the pilgrim.
Is he going to think that the journey to the garden of Eden,
which is a journey ahead forward,
but a journey back in time.
The Garden of Eden is behind all of us and yet it lies ahead of us.
The past is really the future.
He must decide whether he can go on or or or or sit here.
It's a first decision.
Is he going to think that the journey is the journey to the complacency's of the
garden to the beauty and the traction of the garden or is he going to turn as he
actually will?
We have,
we can say that it was have paradise that he writes into an Nantai pastoral port
that is to say one a poet who is always questioning the sense of arrival and is
always going on to new departures.
That's really what the,
the virtual is telling him.
Now this is up to you.
You have arrived here,
you have arrived there where I am,
where virtual is,
or you can even go further.
This has hell.
There's a peculiar language that resonates behind this kind of moral dilemma
which is placed in front of the pilgrims mind.
It's called Félix Gould.
I don't know if you ever have you or those who are readers of Milton may know
what I'm talking about.
Failing schools.
The idea that the fall of man was actually a happy fall because it allows human
beings to even want to go beyond that.
So that's,
that's exactly what is resonating behind this.
And you may sit and therefore turn into an Adam figure who is going back to the
the beauty and innocence,
which the pilgrim doesn't have.
Really,
he has a wisdom now a of the garden or you can go home even further than that.
And then,
uh,
here is the final moment of is this a circle which is now takes over for the,
the,
the Purgatorio a itself no longer expect word or sign for me that's,
that's exactly the,
the,
the teaching of the,
of Virgil has been completed and then he ends with three upright and hall is
they will,
and it were a fault not to act on its bidding.
Therefore,
over the self,
our crown and mitre,
the,
this is the attainment of the free will.
So the whole purgatorial moves between two Poles,
the pole of liberty,
which was Kato's or object,
the object of his quest through the wilderness of the Libyan desert.
And now the attainment of the,
of the free will,
which allows the pilgrim to view it as a condition,
not just the point of arrival,
but they're necessary precondition for moral life.
You can never really have a free and autonomous moral life all in the measure in
which you think you can have the free wheel.
Now the pilgrim is his own responsibility.
And let me say that once it's under,
the guidance will be at the issues,
especially when it comes to palletize.
They will be moral problems where he is in the garden of Eden.
We are going to look at in a moment,
but in paradise aesthetics takes over.
It's no longer an ethical problem then to reverse.
Or you may have heard about,
you know,
reason philosophers who think that life is a range or knowledge is arranged
according to the stages of the aesthetic,
the ethical,
and then the theological Dante reverses this,
that the point that seems to be the most mature is that have dealing with the
aesthetic one,
which others may view as the superficial,
the elementary one,
the one where we,
our perceptions are going to be engaged.
And then,
uh,
the,
the time of this engagement,
even before you can get involved in mature in a ethical experiences than pay
changes.
Uh,
all of us are no ethical dilemma's in paradise.
Once you are in paradise,
you can only enjoy or and get to know the world are all the problems,
had intellectual problems,
not moral,
uh,
moral rituals.
So free,
upright and hold is a will and we're a full to not to act on it.
It's pitting therefore over thyself I crown and Miter they,
this is a kind of secular coronation ceremony,
the crown,
the royal and the episcopal,
uh,
your and the Bishop,
which is a way of,
of uh,
of of consecrating a virtual access,
a kind of lay priest consecrating the attainment of self mastery this moment
which could become a moment of self assertion.
And yet,
uh,
Dante is very careful,
in how he navigates a all of this now from 10 to 28 two Canto 33,
which is the end of the poem.
We come to an area which is another fragment.
You already read,
a kind of segments which we call the literary segment that uh,
with Professor Lumos whom I'm very grateful to,
uh,
covered and explained to you and did with you last last time.
That's a literary segment that goes from 21 to 26.
Now from 28 to 33,
we have a different segment,
which is,
let's call it x,
a pastoral wastage.
It's also the representation of what in a classical literature is called.
L opens are Mainers.
Uh,
you may have seen Adam [inaudible] of this and even in limbo,
that's one of them.
This,
this lovely spot outside of the world of history where something of a,
uh,
relaxation can take place.
And it's also which combines our,
actually with a biblical or two enclosed garden up the,
the,
of the song of songs,
for instance,
or the garden of Eden,
the old two scum cruisers.
Uh,
the interesting thing about,
uh,
Dante's representation of the local somebody knows is that it's never really
outside of history.
It becomes,
that's the assumption.
You know,
you have the garden and you have the city.
This is the,
the dual imagination.
You know,
whenever life becomes unbearable in the city,
you take off and go into your villa in the garden somewhere and find their
relief,
aesthetic relief,
uh,
from,
the,
uh,
the hustle.
Uh,
the time of hustle and bustle of,
of,
of the city,
Dante combines the two.
There's no easier position between them in the sense that the garden of Eden
where he finds himself is going to be the place of a very problematical place,
a place where the pilgrim is engaged in a self confrontation.
He experiences some,
uh,
actually,
terrifying,
a terrifying moments in a Indian counter with,
uh,
with Beatrice.
So the garden of Eden is representing Cantu 28.
And I want to read a few passages.
This is,
uh,
you see how this representation,
is carried out eager now to search from reading from 28 line lines one and
following it,
I'll go pretty,
pretty slowly over this eager now to search within and about the divine forest,
green and dense,
which tempered to my eyes,
the new day,
I left the slope without waiting longer,
taking the levels of very slowly over the ground,
which fragrance on every side.
It's the classic of this as the,
this is the,
uh,
or the,
the,
the warehouse of the pastoral tradition is found here.
Fragrance Asia,
uh,
running brook,
the shades the birds into be rivaling human beings in producing songs,
plenitude of the natural older and,
and,
uh,
even the innocence of the natural odor with the exception of that Dante comes
and the,
he has been cleansed and gone through the wall of fire to further purify him.
He is not a,
the kind of new Adam.
He carries it with them,
the stains of experience in the stage of history.
So there is desire,
uh,
that acts in him.
But let me continue sweet air that I was without change,
with striking on my brow,
with the force only have a gentle breeze,
but which the flattering bows or bent freely on the part where the holy mountain
throws,
it's for a shadow.
Yet we're not so much swayed from the rectus that the little birds in the tops
and not still practice all the arts,
but singing,
they greeted the morning hours with a full gladness among the leaves,
which kept such undertones to their rhymes as gathers from branch to branch.
And the Pinewood of the Cahsi shore where arrows loses its Sirocco.
The interesting thing,
which is some kind of,
uh,
the poignancy of auto biography and,
and,
uh,
is that Dante's imagining the garden of Eden as the,
the pine wood and yet our Vanda which has completely disappeared since then.
Uh,
actually,
uh,
but,
it,
it's,
you can imagine how he would pick the morning walks in the pine trees around the
city and on the way to the,
uh,
the sea.
Uh,
and that for him was,
uh,
the garden,
this mixture of the ordinary and the great sublime imagination.
That's,
that's what I think he's,
he wants to convey to us.
And now he continues.
And I will ask you a question.
I want you to think about what I'm going to ask you because you are expected to
have a shock of recognition in the next three lines.
And these are the lines in English.
I read them in Italian one another little homage to my friend,
Professor Brooks,
uh,
Jack,
Madame [inaudible],
pat,
he lenti pass,
then trying to sell antique Tan to Gil [inaudible] River there on the woman
trusts.
She hadn't died and we told she real conversing
[inaudible] [inaudible] can swear he pushy and English is already my small steps
had brought me so far within the ancient wood that I could not see the place
where it had entered and low.
My going father was prevented by stream with which,
which with,
it's a little waves.
Ben left towards the grass and spraying on its bank.
And this is my question,
what is this?
What to do?
This lines remind you of,
they are meant to remind you of something.
The very beginning of inferno.
Very good,
very good.
Which means
that this is now really a new departure for him,
which means that the garden of Eden is exactly the wilderness that we saw.
And we left behind scene from a different perspective,
which means that the supernatural world is the natural world with a different,
through a different Lens and different perspective.
Okay.
This is,
he's now reenacting exactly the,
the,
the drama of unfair.
No one,
there's no ship wreck.
That mountain has been climbed.
You remember that?
He tried to climb up the mountains,
have been climbed,
a new departure.
It's going to take place.
So here we go.
Then with uh,
this,
this idea of the,
that's what I mean,
the Antipasto will down to the port who dismisses and,
and,
and refuses and repudiates all the temptations of gardens,
all the temptations,
premature Holton,
premature self enclosure into the,
the fiction of God.
This is really the strongest elements that I would have to point out about
what's happening in Canto 28.
Now,
what does he see?
All the waters are purest here would seem to have some deferment in them beside
that,
which conceals nothing through its though it flows quite dark.
And the perpetual shade,
which never let sun or moon shine there with Fita stopped with eyes passed over
beyond the streamlet to look at the great variety of fresh flowering bowels.
And there appeared to me and the word the now is really where the power and
force of an operation and other epiphany of beauty and love to him,
to me as appears of s a southern thing that for one that drives away every other
thought.
A lady all alone who was singing and Colin flowers from flower with which
they're all was painted.
This is Matilda has you have read a woman who goes with dancing,
singing and gathering flowers,
a true picture of fascination of aesthetic fascination for,
for him.
Um,
to give you the sense of how or some resonance.
And in case you are still looking for a term,
uh,
the,
the final paper topic,
uh,
you might want to read.
He said,
uh,
a poem.
Uh,
there is a traditional poetry which is really province are called pastor to Al.
The pastoral pastoral was in the,
uh,
big practitioner.
Is Dante here?
That's what he's writing.
It's the idea of the night who goes through the woods or the medal and meets a
young shepherd.
This gets off.
It's very sensual,
gets off the wood,
Eh,
wounds,
uh,
off the horse and wounds this a young,
young woman and usually ends with a kind of a pun on the x and promises of the
excesses of Paradise.
So it's really a neurotic kind of a song.
But the other practitioner of this,
of this job was Dante,
his own friend Weedo Cavalcanti.
Dante is using the mode and really,
definitely still taking his distance from him.
There is,
there is,
this is a love scene.
There's nothing of the overtones of violence and erotic violence that we look at
our current,
he had celebrated in his own version of the pastoral,
uh,
so,
as genre which is common to them.
Now this instead what he says,
pray fair lady who warned Mr Selves in loves beamed.
Now that has just come out of the circle of lust.
He has been cleansing himself.
And yet this is the,
the,
uh,
lingering trace of his history,
the lingering trace of his body and his humanity.
Here he goes through the garden of Eden as a foreign men who is redeemed and
know quite a redeemed,
certainly not in the Reese,
restore the reinstated into the innocence of the pre lab,
say area our garden.
If I'm to believe that looks,
which I want to be tested,
one of the hottest at Wa,
make please day to come forward to the stream.
So near that I may hear,
which were singers,
you make me recall wearing what was preserved printer at the time,
her mother La series lost her and she the spring.
That's the first and I say a series of three mythological images.
This is the first I think of us preserve data,
but it's also a story of prescription as you know.
Well,
it's stated in the text as the,
the story of the young woman who is walking,
uh,
picking flowers on the plains of Etna in Sicily.
And then death comes and takes her away.
There's a kind of,
uh,
death itself,
loving human beings and taking them.
Uh,
that's one myth.
The second one is a lady turns into dance with feet close together and so on.
And I skipped a few lines and I do not believe such lights shone from beneath
the lids of Venus went through strange ms chance she was pierce,
but her son.
The second image,
I think it's more telling is the story of Venus wounded by the arrows of cubit
and falling in love with cubit.
And I think it's more telling because it's dentist way of casting without going
into psychoanalysis as echo analytical explanations.
But Dante's casting the garden of Eden as also a desire to return to the state
of infancy of the child with the mother only to understand that this is really a
fantasy that would lead them nowhere.
And in fact,
the third image is that of a,
uh,
an erotic images again,
but one of a distance,
three paces that ever kept us apart.
But Hellespont whereas nurses past a bridal settlements,
both did not bear more hatred from Rianda that swelling waters between sasters
and Abby dose than than that for me because it an open then so that this,
this barrier between a Metallica and the pilgrim between Dante and the fantasy
of what the God that movie then may be the mother here is kept and Dante is to
continue.
So he goes on to explain,
she goes on explaining what uh,
uh,
this,
how the mechanics so to say about uh,
uh,
the,
the garden of Eden and then the Canto ends in,
and I look at this end from lines one for [inaudible] and [inaudible] those line
foot one [inaudible] and following those who know time sang of the age of gold
and though it's happy state
perhaps dreamed on Parnassus of this place here,
the human roots was innocent.
Here was lasting spring
and every fruit,
this is the nectar or which each tells,
I turned that right around to my poets and so that they had heard that a
sentence with a smile.
Then I brought my eyes back to the fair lady from dentist point of view.
The perplexity that he feels is the protection of your Virgil and the perplexity
of stations.
They know no more than he does.
He knows no more than they do.
Uh,
what is the other,
the burden of this passage is that the,
uh,
clearly Dante's alluding to the bucolic quality of this place,
but it also suggests that in passing that the ancient,
actually he says that the ancients porch prefigured the garden of Eden,
uh,
in the fabulous visions of the golden age and the Parnassus,
he's establishing your link between the poetic visions and the,
this encounter that he has in the garden of Eden,
both projections of the poetic,
uh,
imagination.
Uh,
uh,
so it also means that the garden of Eden can be like the bucolic fantasy of,
of uh,
uh,
of the poets.
And Parnassus we skipped 29,
which is a,
a story of a really the,
uh,
world history here from as an allegory the page and have a,
a,
a revelation and a,
I will move to Canto 30,
which will take us a little bit of time.
This is the Canto predictably where since Beatrice is the one who was linked
with the number three,
this is the canter where Beatrice will arrive.
And surprisingly,
for those of you who are lovers of this,
uh,
open or hidden symmetries in the poem Canto Fill your paradise is also the
cancer where Beatrice will disappear.
How residents in the poem last for exactly 33,
cantos clearly it's an or an accident.
Her name is three times the good.
She's in the over is linked with three.
It's this kind of way of uh,
uh,
the arcane significance of her presence in the pilgrims are in the leverage,
life.
So,
um,
it can tool that,
uh,
describes a double drama,
the drama of Virgil's appearance and the arrival of Beatrice,
a change of the guard as it were in many ways.
But you have two different moods.
One of allergy for the,
uh,
loss of,
of,
of Virgil and the other one of uh,
uh,
sacred terror at the arrival of,
of,
uh,
of Beatrice.
So it,
uh,
it begins,
um,
he,
he is singing line 17.
Vinny sponsor the banner,
which of course is an echo from the song of songs.
So the erotics of the previous candle continuous.
Now here in the US,
since the song of songs is notoriously one of the blind love poem,
uh,
it continues here in Canto 30,
in anticipation of be a bit of the arrival of Beatrice as the blessed shall rise
at the last Trump each eager from his tomb three cloud voice singing Hallelujah.
There rose on the divine charioteer the voice are so great and elder a hundred
ministers and Ma messengers of eternal life who claim,
who cried Benedictus we Venus.
This is now an illusion is maybe your notes will tell.
You should tell you too.
The greetings of Jesus in the garden when he comes,
I'm sorry to Jerusalem and it says benedict to prevent it.
The which means a Beatrice means a number of things.
First of all,
a paper logical connection between garden and city,
which we have already been seeing here.
The garden is not opposed to the political,
let's say to the city.
It is the history and the garden come together in Dante's imagination,
but there's a further type ology that the Beatrice comes the way Jesus came into
history.
Beatrice will come into the soul of the lover so that she is surrounded.
She has wrapped in a kind of aura of a christological language and she will
become with grace the way one can experience grace in,
in,
in the world through this kind of a direct love on two or oneself,
so Latin again and then a third image and throwing flowers up.
Noun,
money boost or that Lilia,
plaintiff,
another three state,
three phrases in Latin.
He will go on,
translate and get.
Fourth one.
This is a more interesting image because it's taken straight out of the Aeneid
of book six of a virtuous and he it.
So it's already a homage to a who is about to disappear.
You see how the dramas here sort of interwoven,
uh,
the idea of,
what,
what the garden is and how is the garden related to oneself.
One's history,
the idea of the arrival in the meaning of Beatrice into the life of the pilgrim.
And then also the loss of virtual is a poet.
And,
uh,
whatever his vision may be and what are his vision may be,
is indicated by this fragments.
The fragments reverse to the premature death that Virgil celebrates.
And it's very in a giant way in book six of the,
with an,
he is,
uh,
has gone down into hades in order to see the whole of history.
This is the descent into the oracles,
the father,
and to see on Kaiser's,
but it is this whole,
the future that is going to derive and stem from him.
Uh,
and,
and crisis will point out to him the shade of a young man who sits on the side,
sad,
his name is Marcellus,
who will die too young.
And then they will add or throw Lilly's with open hands.
They're literally being a few Muriel symbol.
All right.
The,
the,
the chrysanthemums for instance,
or some such things and in some cultures.
So it's an image of a premature death,
which clearly is linked also to Beatrice,
but who died in a premature premature death,
but also to Virgil because it's the anticipation of the loss of virtual.
It's [inaudible].
It is a safe,
virtuous vision was under the aegis of mortality.
And,
and feel it,
you'd as if as a virtual could never really be thought of as saved because his
song is a song limited to the world of death.
Uh,
and let's see,
um,
tardis containers.
I want,
so at the beginning of the day,
the eastern part or Rosie and the rest of the sky clear and beautiful as the
sun's face come full shaded,
et Cetera,
uh,
with a lady appeared to me,
this is Beatrice Gert.
With all of over white way or look a few elegance.
Listen to how he describes the collars,
the fashions,
Gert with all of our over a white veil clouded under green mantle with a color
of a living flame.
In my spirit,
I call that the Italian flag.
By the way,
the way she seems to be,
the red,
white and green and my spirit,
which now so long has not been overcome with all trembling her presence without
having more knowledge by the eyes through hidden virtual that came from her felt
all love.
Great power.
This is a rewriting of the poem of the autobiography of Dante that you remember
reading the Vita Nuova.
Uh,
he's experiencing the of Beatrice exactly the kind of effects the she has over
him.
Uh,
the,
the core three love,
the sweet new style,
the trembling,
the an ability to speak as soon as I love to virtual that smoked on my side,
which already had pierced me before I was out of my boyhood.
I turned to the left with a confidence of a little child that runs to his mother
when he's afraid are in distress.
To say to Virgil,
not a drop of blood is left in me that does not tremble.
I know the marks of the engine flame,
he's scared and turns to Virgil and he's about to say,
and we'll say the famous lines.
I know the marks of the engine flame,
which he said translation of the words Dido will speak when she meets an ies in
Hades,
I know the marks of the ancient Rome and now the image of death and mortality
taken from the Aeneid.
Dante's linking Virgil with that kind of metaphor,
uh,
in that sort of limitation of passion.
But Virgil had left us bereft of him.
Virtual,
sweetest father Virgil tumor giving myself for my salvation,
not the,
the,
all the ancient mother lost avail my cheeks wash with do that.
They should not be staying again with tears.
And this is Beatrice's first words,
Dante,
because virtual leaves the,
we've not,
we've not yet for thou must weep for another salt,
like an admirable who goes to poop.
I'm proud to say demand the server on the other ships and heart and them and the
work.
So on the left side of the car,
we're not turned up the sound of my name,
which is noted here of necessity.
I saw the lady who first appeared to me veiled and that the angelic festival
direct horizon will be on the stream or ready.
The veil that fell from her head and circled with Minerva's leaves.
Did Not let her be plainly seen,
royally,
still stern and have be a bearing.
She continued like one who while she speaks holds back his hottest words.
Look at me.
Well I am.
I am indeed.
Beatrice.
How there's thou approach the mountain,
this darn hot.
Know that here man is happy.
Um,
well,
a number of things here,
uh,
virtual has disappeared now hours alone.
So that's what I call the self confrontation with his past.
Who is Beatrice?
How am I going to account for my failings to be addressed?
And what is this you're going to expect of me?
She's harsh.
Uh,
the line of the harsh language of love to the point,
if I may be a little bit too too,
without really lessening the intensity of this passage,
this passage pretty intense.
But I feel that I have to tell you,
uh,
a little,
to distract you a little bit for 10 seconds.
Um,
both this has written about this passage,
one of the beautiful,
beautiful essay,
um,
on,
on this scene and he says,
this is the only time that Dante really made a mistake because we,
it is spoke to me the way he spoke.
She spoke to virtual tool.
Dante,
I would have said to her,
look,
if that's the way you feel,
I'm going to go right back.
And,
uh,
but [inaudible] say that this is a,
this is a contemporary,
a visionary like,
uh,
like Barack is not Dante.
Where we are told is that this is the first and only time in the poem.
The dentist name is hurt.
Dante.
She will never call him Donald again.
And he has never been called Dante before.
In other words,
this is the point where the poem from the epic that has been the epic of his
idea,
the epic of hope,
the pilgrim laws,
they can longing and memory,
uh,
between hope and memory.
Um,
uh,
the poem of justice.
Now it becomes an autobiography.
Now with his own story,
there is a shift in genre from an epic story,
from the loss of Virgil,
the epic poet,
to an autobiographical focus.
Dante,
this is you,
the specificity and it reduced the ability of his own experience.
Dante,
he says,
and he will laugh with not with her answer and he will,
he will add that his name has is here,
registered out of necessity.
And what is the necessity that he has?
What's,
what's the necessity about,
speaking of oneself,
why would one be go on?
Speaking of us have one speech oneself.
Um,
uh,
I'll that because one wants to be exemplary.
Two others.
One believes that what,
what one has experienced is crucial for somebody else's self knowledge,
somebody else's experience or one once who exempt vituperation from his own
name.
It's the,
I'm paraphrasing Dante's words and they,
the way,
the way he registered to them in this,
uh,
philosophical texts that he writes called the banquet where he speaks about
himself and he says there are two people who have spoken about themselves in
exemplary ways.
One is Augustan in their confessions,
a book that I have asked you repeatedly to read and I have read from.
And the other one is [inaudible] that I have alluded to in the consolation of
philosophy,
the philosopher who is in jail and seeks to find comfort to the,
uh,
the,
the imputations of criminal conduct,
uh,
laid on him by thinking about philosophy and talking about himself.
And whereas Augustan of course is discussing his own,
his own conversion.
So the idea of the necessity is a,
both a Dante's alluding to,
to auto-biographical texts,
uh,
both of which make it,
the,
the talking about oneself in need as he calls it,
uh,
a necessity.
Uh,
so this now will continue.
And the,
with Canto 30,
uh,
the first thing that she will do,
Beatrice will do,
and we'll turn true canto 31.
There's an account of Canto 30,
continues with,
uh,
the story of how his,
um,
failures when she died is told in the Vita Nuova.
He went on looking for someone who could replace a Beatrice.
And now Dante goes on,
uh,
asking,
actually indulging in a confession,
literally an Augustinian moment and other parts of the autobiographical moment
and a confessional form.
Uh,
and this is a,
let me just read a few,
a few lines here before we move on.
Uh,
oh,
thou that art on that side of the sacred river,
she began again turning against me.
The point of a speech,
which even with the edge that seemed sharp to me and continued with a pause,
say safe.
This is true to such an accusation that confession must needs be joined.
My faculties were so confounded that my voice began and was spent before it was
released from its organs.
She foreboder little then said,
but thinkers that a phrase that should remind you,
I know that it's too little and they would not be,
uh,
too demanding,
but it should remind you,
um,
what effect this is Francesca.
So this is what what Dante was asking Francesca in Canto five and now it's
Beatrice.
The roles are inverted.
Who's asking Dante to resume as if,
where that confession of a feeling that Francesca hidden a gun in Canto five of
of in fair no.
What thing,
what thinkers Dow answer me for they sad memories are not yet destroyed in the
by the water confusion and fear.
Mingle together,
draw forth from my mouth.
A Yes such that to hear it,
there was no need of sight as a cross bow shot with two great strains breaks the
code.
Uh,
let me just go on after a with lines 36,
after he even a bitter cy,
I had already,
I had hardly the voice to answer and the lip shaped it with difficulty weeping.
I said,
present things with a floor falls pleasure.
Turned my steps as soon as you face was hid.
Uh,
the,
uh,
he's alluding exactly as he did in the Vita Nuova to his change of heart.
As soon as Beatrice died and now we can,
she can change.
And she had style kept silence or denied whether confessors that fault to be no
less plain by such a judge it known,
but went from a men's home,
uh,
breaks forth condemnation of his sin in our code that will turn turns back
against the edge,
nevertheless,
in order that their mason now bear the shame of the wonderings.
And then at the time hearing the sirens be stronger.
Lay aside the sewing of tears and Harken social though here,
how my buried fresh should have directed the the other way.
Never the nature outside before the beauties are greatest,
the family members,
et cetera.
Um,
the passage is extraordinary because it helps us to glos retrospectively,
eh,
but it was a fairly mysterious allegory in a purgatory.
You remember where Dante meets the sirens or dreams of this Irene.
Um,
and then a lady appeared is hiring is a,
was an allegory of a temptation and erotic temptation.
Someone who wants to rework the pilgrim and promises happiness.
You remember,
I'm going to make you happy.
You're on.
You need to go nowhere else.
Uh,
and now,
uh,
and then we,
there was,
there was also the appearance of a,
uh,
a mysterious woman,
equally mysterious woman who manages to um,
uh,
send away,
the,
this hiring.
She,
if she wakes up the pilgrim and the journey there can can continue.
And if you recall,
we are saying,
well,
we don't know who this mysterious woman is though.
There are a number of hints.
I had read this path of the poem before.
You have probably Eh,
and uh,
uh,
and this Beatrice,
Beatrice.
So it was a kind of an allegory of the confrontation of two women decided on the
one hand and on the other hand,
uh,
this unknown mysterious Beatrice.
Now this scene just,
uh,
makes it clear because what be it?
He says you have to make a confession in case shame.
Now bear the shame of the wondering said another time hearing the silence be
stronger.
Lay aside the soul of tears and Hark and thou shall hear how my bill flesh and
so on.
So she is now glossing the scene of a of this.
Irene there appeared in Canto 19 but there is more to it but there's a little
phrase that Dante is using,
uh,
and other abilities using for him.
Another time when you hear the siren,
which means that there's hiring,
it's not just the encounter with this Irene is not just an event that happened
in the past.
It can happen all over again and other time.
In other words,
it can still happen in the future,
which means that Danfoss conversion,
which is really what this poem has been telling us especially now,
which has reached this kind of autobiographical quality is not over and done
with that.
It is a conversion has to be understood as unknown going journey and that the
future itself is fraught with temptations just as much as it was fraught with
fraught with them stations in the past.
What Dante is changing is the other stealing an idea of a conversion or that
takes place once and for all and this making is replacing that paradigm with a
different paradigm,
a paradigm of a conversion in its openness to time.
With the idea that it is an ongoing process.
So you have a look of what the,
the,
the point that technique is done is remembering a scene of the past and glossing
that encounter that amputation was Irene moved away,
dispelled by the arrival of Beatrice.
Beatrice is talking once again about the siren and other time,
meaning I know who she was in Canton 19 of in the dream of pantry.
I think she may come back again.
And I was,
once again,
this is the anti pastoral imagination of the poet.
Do not believe that you can never stop on the way,
do not ever believe that they are choose.
They're going to be unchallenged or untested in time.
And that thing that this is a way of,
uh,
truly,
casting Dante for what it is that poet of,
uh,
the poet of,
open to the power of the future and,
and drawn to the idea that the future is still a part of his,
uh,
his experience.
And then by the way,
he goes on,
which I would really take us up.
But that's the essential point.
A truly the though is this is a line 55,
uh,
the o's at the forest shaft of deceptive things to have risen up after me who
was such no longer no young girl or a vanity of such brief worth,
should have been Thai wings downward to a wig,
more shots,
a young chick weights for two or three,
but in vain is,
and let's spread the Rado and so on.
Uh,
this is,
uh,
another,
literally the illusion to the poems that Dante wrote for what he called the
[inaudible],
the,
the young woman,
uh,
that Beatrice seems to be Ma remind him,
of,
um,
and now we come to,
uh,
Canto 33,
the end of purgatory,
uh,
the end of purgatory where I really want to,
um,
uh,
focus on one image,
one image in particular,
which is a which,
which is,
uh,
the image of a prophecy that,
Beatrice,
we are at the end of time,
pull the Tori and uh,
he goes on,
she goes on,
I'm sorry,
promising eh deliver,
who will come.
Uh,
the argument now is no longer about Dante himself.
It's an argument about history.
Is there a deliverance for history?
Uh,
is it possible for the whole human family to go back to a condition that at
least if you're not the garden of Eden as such,
from the point of view,
which we can see at least the towers of the true city.
That's the way Dante calls it in the political tract.
Monaca so he's talking about,
uh,
a figure that man to history that will enter history at the end of time.
That's why I stress that dramatic.
The poem is literally poets,
the at the,
at the outer edge of time.
There's no time when we didn't go into paradise once again.
So let me tell you what this,
and we'll try to explain it for you.
Uh,
lines 30 and falling.
And she said to me from fear and shame,
I will have the free day cells henceforth that was amazed.
No longer speak like one that dreams no,
that the vessel,
she's tough.
She's tough.
She's a,
she's attacking him.
Uh,
uh,
she will be the teacher and from now on,
no,
that the vessel,
the serpent broke was and is not.
But let him know that it has the blame.
Be assured that God's vengeance,
fierceness,
ESOP,
not for all the time should the eagle probably the eagle of the empire,
but without air that left his feathers on the cars it became became monster.
And then pray for I see assuredly and therefore tell of it.
Stars already near to give us the time.
Secure for more check and hindrance when a 510 and five one sent from God shall
slay the feverish woman and the giant who sins with her.
And perhaps my doc Taylor famous in this,
things persuades the less because in the fashion it clouds their mind,
but soon the facts,
she'll be deniers that will solve this hard enigma without loss of flocks and
pour.
So she delivers an enigma and enigmatic prophecy.
Enigma is a word that obviously means mystery,
but it's also linked to allegory.
You know,
you talk about irony allegory,
they'll tropes that drum Marion's place under the same,
a general subdivision would say it's an enigma,
it's mysterious,
it's not quite clear.
And the lack of clarity only adds I think to,
to the the fear,
uh,
in the speculations of,
of course about what this is.
It's a new medical symbol is,
which is recently,
he says it's at 510 and five.
Uh,
that's the way through to the 510 and five,
515.
Um,
you do know that numbers we have been talking a little bit about this.
Numbers are viewed as containing medieval numerical symbolism views,
numbers as containing the essence and the secrets actually of creation that
would go writing Isidore of Seville goes over writing sensors as take the number
away from things and things will perish,
will fall apart.
What is a Pythagorean idea,
but keeps all things together is just this sense of call it musical rhythmic
car,
a numerical ordering.
Uh,
and of course the greater,
the number that maybe everybody knows is a six x six,
which is the number of,
of the antichrist.
Right?
So Nancy is writing a 500,
one and five,
what on Earth could it be?
All of the speculations?
I could,
uh,
they're hilarious of this.
What they could mean.
There are those who believe.
Well,
it's really refers to the year 13,
15.
We have no reason to believe that he says verse 800,
the Year of Charlemagne declaring the holy Roman empire and five,
one,
five and the issue 1315.
So Dante's really thinking about an imminent event in his own time.
There's nothing in the text that will allow us to see this and allow us to make
it credible.
So what is it?
Uh,
actually it was found that the way,
the best way to describe it is really in written in the x V in a 510 and five,
um,
that this is the best way to try to make any sense of this prophecy and of
course,
and other materials,
interpretations that are just regale to you for your own reluctance.
Temporal relaxation.
This was immediately became the,
uh,
five x and Dukes.
Uh,
he,
uh,
between 19 and 23 and 1943,
this was a prophecy of Mussolini,
of all people who would come and deliver the,
the,
the world and other ridiculous of course interpretation.
But it was fun.
But some very good back to simple tennis.
It's amazing.
The two historians,
one actually,
historically when I literally historian and therefore they took two different
views that in the medieval illustrations,
there is a moment,
by the way,
I'm just preamble this.
This is the founder,
medieval illustrations of the mass.
There's a moment in the mass with this,
this whole cold,
uh,
or prayers,
you know,
the,
the idea that Christ is coming Sacramento and they have the,
have the,
sure it is truly right and uh,
and dressed and the Latin,
uh,
the you used to mass v The d and it's always written like this.
And they explained,
we annex across the joins,
a human and the divine.
So that's really the prayer or the enigma of Beatrice is for the apocalyptic end
of time.
The time when,
uh,
Christ will return to Earth.
The first time he came.
First of all as a human being,
five 10 and 500 the second time,
who will come first of his divinity,
so 510 and and and and five the divinity and the humanity.
Second,
the second element,
the to humanity and divinity joined together by the x of the cross Drake
discovery,
number of infinite problems that I have.
I hope I'll have,
let me bear with me for a couple of minutes so that I can tell you more about
this.
If this is an apocalyptic symbol,
this was here.
You understand what we mean by an apocalyptic symbol,
right?
Apocalyptic prophecy.
The prophecy apocalypse means for visionary coming from the apocalypse of St
John and implying the Dante believes in some kind of imminent end of time,
right?
History is coming to an end.
If he believed in this,
and this is to be understood as an apocalyptic symbol of an imminent end of
time.
This would make Dante what is called a Joa kissed and they have to explain to
you who this man is.
If there's a man by the name of joke,
him of flora who was a,
we'll see him in paradise.
Joe hemo flora who had a theory of history in a kind of Chipper,
tight structure [inaudible] flora.
Uh,
the,
the idea is that history is pattern on the trinity.
So there is an age of the father which roughly goes from creation to the time of
the biblical patriarchs.
Then there is the age of the son that goes from the time of the incarnation to
roughly 1260,
his own time.
This is Joe came flora and then this and the age of the spirit that goes from
the,
the uh,
the time of 1260,
when thanks to the fraternal orders,
all structures and only institutions will disappear and Hume and mankind will
experience a time of brotherhood and chastity.
There'll be no marriages,
there'll be no state,
they will be nothing.
And I say California is already anticipated in seen by this great figure of Joe
came of Laura.
If the [inaudible] were Joe,
a joke is that could treat a number of problems.
What I have just been describing to you was viewed as a most heretical theory of
history.
Why was it heretical?
Because in effect,
joke him of flora was,
uh,
with this theory and age of the father,
the age of the son and the age of the spirit was in effect and doing the unity
of the Trinity,
uh,
this to hey the truth is no longer simple.
Telisa together he's dividing the trinet into three distinct parts and no less a
great theologian of the Dantes on time,
whom Dante will encounter very soon in paradise.
And they are going to discuss joke Aamer flora together.
Bonaventure we'll go on really,
uh,
writing a piece in order to declare joke Aamer flora heretical.
So if this is a,
a very powerful explanation that Dante's regal alluding to the second coming at
the end of time,
the DXV,
uh,
when Christ will return to Earth to restore the messianic advent to restore
justice to the world,
uh,
and it will come first of all in glory of the divinity first and the humanities
second,
both joined by the cross,
the humanity and the divinity together.
Uh,
then,
and if it's not an uh,
uh,
is he an apocalyptic writer?
I doubted his an apocalyptic writer.
This is no poet.
I know,
and I think we have given plenty of evidence of this or the last two months who
cares more about the institutions who believes that the institutions are
history.
And of course he attacks them in the measuring in which he thinks that they have
to be a revitalized,
refreshed,
and improved.
But you cannot go on attacking the institutions,
uh,
from,
without really believing in their vital importance.
In history.
It talks about the empire.
He talks about the church.
It talks about,
um,
uh,
law.
He talks about,
uh,
family,
et cetera.
They're old institutions that preserve their enduring importance.
So if it's not an apocalyptic writer,
where is he then I think that this is an allusion to the coming of the second
coming,
but without removing all the joke,
historic,
uh,
peripheral area that our company that prophecy,
this is indeed the time.
It doesn't refer to the now of history,
the first two at a time that nobody can really fathom and nobody can really
know.
So I'm giving,
I have given you a reading of this passage and giving you a glimpse of the,
the logical complications that are usually a company where it would seem to be
such a neat,
uh,
discovery or needs glossing over an image.
And of course with a,
this prophecy,
the poem will come to an end and the appointment comes to an end with a Dante
who goes,
and then we'll talk about this image again,
who has to be ritually immersed.
He will be merged into two rivers,
the river Levy,
the liver of forgetfulness,
and the river.
You know,
the river of good memories.
It's a ritual roper operational.
This is toward the end of Canto 33 that reminds you of the ritual actions,
a beginning of Canto one,
but Dante washes his face and there's two gird his loins with you.
Remember with the reed that was growing spontaneously on the shore of a,
of the sea,
but well done.
People's own chain is the two rivers leafy and you know,
the live flow out of the same source.
And then he says like tool,
lazy friends,
friends who are fond of each other,
they go on parting leisurely.
That's the image that users,
what is interesting is that his thinking of memory and forgetfulness,
the leafy and you know,
as entailing a child so that there's no Eurasia,
which is not at the same time and memory that each contains the other.
And Dante we'll go has a lot to say about forgetful memory,
especially in the,
the way the poem will be written.
And finally,
uh,
with a line,
the product,
the whole poem ends with the whole Purgatorio ends with align that obviously,
uh,
remind you of,
um,
the,
the uh,
the video end of the inferno from north most holy water.
This is Canto 33.
I came forth again,
remade even as new plants,
the very language over the beginning of Purgatorio one,
uh,
renewed with new leaves,
pure and ready to mound to the stars.
Dante once again now is,
uh,
at the top fold to the story and he will fly next like lightening on to the moon
and we shall see him and this guy in the planet today,
epic.
Cosmological.
I pick that,
uh,
we'll start on the next time,
but now I'm sure you have,
uh,
questions and we'll go doing okay with timing.
So,
so please,
uh,
shoot.
Yeah.
Yes.
Great.
Perfect.
Could you just expand on how that fits in the be the
perfect progression,
not understanding
very good question.
Help us understand or become closer to God.
Yes.
Uh,
the,
the question is that I spoke about,
uh,
Canto 30 of Purgatorio.
I spoke about the transition formal transition from,
uh,
the,
the structure of the epic with a virtual,
the poet of the epic.
And then moving on to effect,
I spoke of the autobiographical,
uh,
first of all that we're,
we're,
Beatrice,
uh,
refers to Coles,
Dante by name.
So it's his story.
Dante don't cry because Virgil has disappeared.
I'm going to give you a chance to cry for other reasons and then goes on into a
confession,
which is an Augustinian form.
But also it's true.
I mentioned that is a transition too.
I mean,
I did say that in a paradise is,
uh,
is,
is the world of aesthetics where the ethical or ordering,
uh,
is liquidated in a certain sense.
So the question is how does this respond to the whole arc of the poem?
What kind of,
uh,
how,
what am I,
what am I really saying about the whole experience of the poem to make,
make the aesthetic,
uh,
essential for knowledge?
That's,
that's the argument.
And that is true.
I,
I really welcome this question because that's the way I'm reading poetry as
opposed to whatever way of knowing I have.
I keep saying this,
uh,
that it's really a way of knowing.
Um,
uh,
oh,
from her point of view,
a philosophical kind of a poetry realizing and keeping in mind that there are
always distinctions and,
and ongoing quarrels between poetry and,
uh,
and philosophy.
Uh,
but Lisa is say,
uh,
like any true ethics.
This is a general pronouncement that doesn't make it,
but it's a kind of premise to what I'll be saying later.
Any through ethics can only be successful in the measuring,
which it stops operating.
That's when the ethics is really,
uh,
you can say that it has done its job as it were.
So we enter a world where now is the world of paradise and uh,
and Dante goes on,
uh,
representing this,
this world.
He'll never forget the earth.
It's,
I have to qualify that even in paradise.
He's going to look at the earth.
He celebrates the greatest aspect of human life.
Uh,
work,
love things that join,
join the community together.
He will see also the distortions that are going on where they are in the,
in the empire,
in the,
the political life or in the life of the church.
This also this,
every time that there is a retrospective look,
there is a kind of dismay that he will feel.
So there is,
there is all of that,
but the emphasis is on the,
the world of paradise is about dance.
It's about songs is about,
it's about love.
It's about stars were in each other.
It's about spectacular.
Uh,
Ms. Hanson,
the pyrotechnics of a,
that he is about the different forms of light.
What is this about exactly what I call the aesthetic experiences are all a
poetic,
uh,
artistic experiences?
Well,
the first thing you have to keep in mind,
this damn Tiberi things of a theology that is really like poetry and the origin
of this poem that he's like poetry in the sense that both are part of,
or if you wish,
and even won't even call it theology,
but let me call it finish that sentence is a theology says,
I put it in the sense that it's,
it's a playful theology,
a way of understanding that the essence of God now can be seen in his comical,
uh,
figuration a god who is the artist that God,
who is,
who,
who thinks that this is the way in which human beings we're supposed to.
When it first created in the garden of Eden,
where we're really in a garden meant to play.
And that's where we're going back to.
It's a way of casting the divinity and the most as beauty,
uh,
a duty that that also encompasses,
the good.
But beyond that,
beyond a playful or Ludic theology,
this idea of an aesthetic theology,
there's something else that dentists saying about the proximity between the
poetic and the religious.
It's not a connection that is usually made because we tend to believe that the
poetic,
it's just the world of deceptions make believe.
The fact is that both the poetic and the religious,
and we can say that even about the philosophical if you wish,
they respond to profound impulses within us.
Let emotions that we have,
the,
you know,
all,
you see beauty and you tremble in the presence of beauty,
whether it's a human beauty,
its natural beauty or artistic beauty,
whatever,
whatever it is that we are in conflict and there is something that responds in
us.
And the same thing about the idea of all and the idea of a discovery or sense of
the sublime.
Whenever you have what we call a religious experience and they too have not
neatly separated.
This is what drives the poet in the journey of Paradise.
This is where the,
the,
the actual source of,
uh,
of his inspiration,
that's the novelty that Dante represents and which probably some romantic poets
much later I'm talking about the 19th century,
uh,
have been trying to,
to,
uh,
restore,
grasp or understand.
You do have that in,
uh,
in,
in Dante.
Do you have it for instance,
in the Bible,
I dare say you do.
Because whenever we think about,
you know,
it's so,
or so many courses at Yale,
I used to be taught,
I don't look at the,
uh,
at,
at the offerings anymore because I think I know them by heart,
not for any other reason about the Bible is literature,
which is great,
but you know,
the,
the idea,
the underlying idea is always that the Bible can only has to be that guy,
you know,
novels.
Uh,
and that's,
that's all right.
That's very good.
But that's an Oro to say that as I did that the song of songs is a fantastic,
I said it 10 minutes ago,
that the song of songs is a fantastic love poem.
What I'm really saying is that the poetic is already in itself proximate to the
religious,
so that we,
when we think about the Bible in literature,
we are ready re unfreezing another version of this problem,
which is that of the Dante presents as the religious in this and the poetic in
paradise.
I hope I've answered your question.
Okay.
Thank you.